[Musique]
bonsoir ça va vous êtes recharger
c'est mon passage
d'abord je voulais vous dire à quel
point j'étais heureuse d'être avec vous
ce soir
vous est il déjà arrivé de devoir
prendre seul une décision
avec un enjeu qui vous dépasse
à 13 ans je suis victime d'un accident
c'est l'été il fait beau je suis à la
montagne avec mes parents je suis
totalement insouciante
et j'ai un très grave accident de
balançoire plus rien et tu as à plat de
multiples fractures
il faut opérer en urgence le plus
inquiétant c'est que la croissance de ma
jambe gauche est menacée le médecin qui
me prend en charge indique à mes parents
qui sont totalement prostrée à côté de
moi qu'il ya deux possibilités pour
pouvoir réduire ses fractures la
première c'est une intervention
chirurgicale sous anesthésie générale la
deuxième possibilité c'est plusieurs
interventions manuelles qu'il effectuera
sous anesthésie locale
mes parents sont hyper inquiète
totalement prostrée à côté de moi ils
doivent prendre une décision qui les
dépasse à votre avis quelle a été leur
décision
pouvez vous pouvez levé la main pour la
une
et vous pouvez levé la main pour la 2
et bien aucune aucune parce que ma mère
s'est tourné vers moi et m'a dit et toi
myriam quel est ton choix
à 13 ans je réfléchis pas j'écoute ce
qui me vient ce qui me paraît être la
bonne décision à cet instant et
d'ailleurs je choisis la décision que
mes parents n'auraient sans doute pas
prise celle de cinq interventions
manuelles sous anesthésie locale oui je
m'écoute je m'écoute parce que j'ai
confiance en ce médecin je m'écoute
parce que j'ai une peur bleue de
l'anesthésié générale et puis au fond je
m'écoute parce que c'est peut-être ma
façon à moi de participer à ces
réparations
mais le plus important
c'est que je m'écoute parce que des
personnes en qui j'ai confiance
mes parents m'amène tam écouter dans une
posture d'égal à égal dans une posture
d'adulte à adulte
et ce qui est totalement fou c'est que
du haut de mes 13 ans j'ai fait le bon
choix
vous savez pourquoi j'ai fait le bon
parce que depuis cet accident j'ai
grandi
de 6 cm
et des deux jambes
et depuis cet accident je n'ai aucune
cicatrice ni aucune douleur ce qui est
fou c'est que du haut de mes 13 ans j'ai
pris la bonne décision alors que l'on je
me dépassait totalement
et depuis ce jour là ma petite voix
intérieure mon intuition sont les socles
de ma confiance la confiance est devenu
mon ami dans tous ces moments clés où
tout peut basculer qu'il s'agisse de mon
orientation de mes jobs de mes amours de
mes enfants de ma santé de mes proches
tiens parlons-en de mes proches le
nombre de fois où je les ai entendus me
dire mais mais rien de franchement tu
comment tu fais pour quitter une
entreprise qui fait rêver tant de
personnes non mais franchement qu'est ce
qui te passe par la tête pour oser tenir
de tels propos à ton boss non mais
franchement tu crois pas qu'à 55 ans tu
ferais mieux de penser sereinement à ta
retraite plutôt que de vouloir te lancer
dans une nouvelle aventure
entrepreneuriale
alors oui je doute je doute je doute
parfois même je pleure
mais je finis toujours par écouter ma
petite voix intérieure mon ami la
confiance
et ce soir
je vous partage une très très bonne
nouvelle c'est que la confiance est en
chacun de nous elle ne demande qu'à
s'exprimer il suffit de l'écouter une
fois pour qu'elle s'invite souvent
simplement elle a besoin d'attention
elle a besoin de respect
elle a besoin d'amour ouais
d'amour aussi
je suis myriam multigner je suis
sparring partner et j'accompagne les
dirigeants les managers les
entrepreneurs à écouter cette petite
voix intérieure pour qu'ils puissent
faire des choix qui leur ressemble
notamment dans ces moments clés où ils
doivent prendre seul des décisions avec
des enjeux qui les dépasse
c'est un dirigeant de l'audiovisuel
public qui un jour alors que je le
challenge est un petit peu dans sur une
situation très sensible j'étais dans une
posture d'égal à égal
et c'est lui qui me dit un jour mais
myriam vous n'êtes pas une couche vous
êtes une vraie sparring-partner
sparring partner
alors je me suis un peu renseigné oui
sparring partner ça vient du monde de la
boxe
est en fait c'est vrai au fond que comme
un partenaire d'entraînement je monte
sur le ring d'égal à égal et je
questionne jeu challenge j'écoute ce est
leader sur tous les problèmes qu'ils se
posent au quotidien sur ce qui les
empêche de dormir
je les amène en fait tu as écouté pour
être mieux écoutés de leurs actionnaires
mieux écouter de leurs collaborateurs
pour pouvoir éviter ce burn out qui
gronde maintenant à tous les étages
je les amène à s'écouter pour qu' il
puisse prendre soin d'eux-mêmes et
prendre soin de leur équipe parce que un
dirigeant qui sait prendre soin de lui
ou d'elle c'est naturellement prendre
soin de ses équipes et puis ne vous a
pas échappé à quel point ces dirigeants
doivent prendre de plus en plus de
décisions dans un laps de temps de plus
en plus courts avec des enjeux qui les
dépasse de plus en plus alors oui il y a
urgence pour que chacun de nous nous
écoutions notre petite voix intérieure
pour une raison toute simple c'est tout
simplement d'éviter que les autres
prennent des décisions à notre place
alors oui c'est pas facile parce qu'on
est tous aux prises avec notre éducation
avec nos croyances avec nos peurs
sans oublier ce syndrome de l'imposteur
qui paralyse et puis on n'a plus le
temps on n'a plus le temps parce que
maintenant chaque seconde doit être
productive
ah et puis il ya celles qui
nous endort
doucement
mais sûrement
la routine et oui la routine
tiens
parmi vous qui se sent aja à sa juste
qui se sent à sa juste place
est-ce que vous pouvez lever la main
vous faites pas très nombreux qui parmi
vous à une idée totalement
enthousiasmante de son futur job
pas très nombreux non plus mais je vous
rassure je vous rassure vous n'êtes pas
les seuls c'est une quête universelle
tenez rien qu'aux états unis en 2021 ce
sont 38 millions de personnes qui ont
donné leur démission
mais c'est pas ça le chiffre le plus
important c'est que 40 % d'entre elles
n'avaient pas trouvé d'emploi
il faut c'est la quête universelle de sa
juste place et la période que nous
traversons ne fait qu'accélérer ce
chemin vers soi
mais la très très bonne nouvelle parce
qu'il ya encore une autre c'est que 85 %
des emplois qui existeront en 2030
n'existe pas aujourd'hui ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'on va créer nos
emplois ça veut dire qu'on va créer nos
emplois de rêve et oui parce que toutes
les semaines toutes générations
confondues j'entends jean peu plus une
mon job je m'ennuie en fait je sais ce
que je veux faire mais je sais pas
comment y aller je suis perdu j'ai perdu
je suis complètement perdue et puis en
fait le boulot que je fais en fait il
n'a pas de sens
y'a pas de change
il ya urgence il ya urgence à faire
bouger les lignes
alors vous voyez bien nous le sentons
tous à quel point il est difficile
d'écouter sa petite voix intérieure de
la faire sienne et de la transformer en
actions
bah oui mais rien de très gentil mais on
fait comment
j'ai un petit programme un petit
programme extrêmement simple à vous
partager ce soir qui est activable par
chacun d'entre nous
trois clés la première on écoute les
signaux de notre corps la seconde on
entre tout ce qui nous met en joie pour
comprendre ce qui nous anime et 3 on
monte sur le ring avec son sparring
partner je vous parlais des signaux de
notre corps tous les jours notre corps
nous parle et on s'empresse de dire non
ça va passer prenez l'exemple des
insomnies des spasmes dans le ventre une
gorge qui se sert toujours dans la même
situation de la tristesse
un sentiment de vide ou de submersion
tous ces signaux nous indique que nous
ne sommes pas notre juste place alors
non je vous dis pas de quitter votre job
non je vous dis simplement c'est
important d'écouter notre corps parce
qu'il nous parle il est notre guide
notre ami de la même façon quand tout va
bien quand nous sommes alignés comme
nous sommes à notre juste place notre
corps nous parler nous envoie des
signaux
regain d'énergie
fluidité
synchronicité présentation hyper fluide
relation hyper facile
notre corps nous donne des pépites
d'information en permanence
alors maintenant je vais vous donner la
deuxième clé la deuxième clé c'est
d'ancrer ce qui nous met en joie pour
comprendre ce qui nous anime et là je
vous propose est quelque chose
d'extrêmement simple qui y perd
activable et qui va nécessiter
simplement de vous doter d'un petit
carnet un petit carnet alors pas celui
ci spécialement mais un carnet dédié à
votre musique intérieure un carnet qui
vous suit partout avec son petit stylo
et dans ce petit carnet je vais vous
inviter en fait à déposer ancrer tous
ces moments formidables qui traverse vos
journées ce peut être une présentation
qui vous a ressources et ça peut être
une main sur l'épaule qui vous a
réchauffé ça peut être un compliment qui
vous a fait du bien ça peut être aussi
une chanson qui vous a fait frissonner
ça peut être tout simplement un regard
qui vous a fait grandir tous ces petits
moments qui traversent nos journées
ecrivez-le est noté la date le moment et
surtout
surtout ce qui vous a mis en joie est ce
que vous avez ressenti à ce moment là
vous allez voir c'est magique alors oui
j'en entends chuchoter se diraient les
gentils elle un peu has been avec son
petit carnet nous on est plutôt dans la
rue on se voit en train de décrire votre
petit carnet alors que jusqu'à présent
on est en train de s'écrouler sur notre
portable essayez et vous verrez alors il
y en a qui peuvent aussi me dire non
mais t'es gentil ton petit carnet c'est
pas nouveau on a déjà essayé ça marche
pas alors et puis toute façon faire tout
ça tout seul moi ça me c'est pas mon
truc j'y arrive pas j'ai du mal en fait
à me projeter
pas dans ces cas-là ce que je vous
propose c'est de monter sur le ring avec
votre partenaire d'entraînement mais pas
n'importe qui quelqu'un en qui vous avez
confiance
quelqu'un ac avec laquelle vous êtes
dans une posture d'égal à égal c'est
essentiel parce que c'est le seul moment
qui vous permettra est la seule posture
qui vous permettra d'avoir cette
relation de choeur à coeur et non pas de
tête à tête non c'est plus le mental qui
va agir c'est votre coeur se sont vos
ressentis
et avec cette personne qui peut être un
professeur un mentor qui peut être un
ami un professeur un parent un
professionnel ou une professionnelle
vous allez voir à quel point
c'est magique et comme je vous le disais
de plus en plus de dirigeants ont
compris à quel point c'était bon de
s'écouter de s'écouter pour faire des
choix qui leur ressemble au delà au delà
de leur statut des choix qui sont en
phase avec qui ils elles sont mais il ya
une autre raison pour laquelle ses
dirigeants se sont mis à s'écouter c'est
la communication intergénérationnelle
et je pense que ça va vous parler parce
qu'en fait c'est pour rentrer en
communication harmonieuses avec les
18-40 ans les digital natives et oui
vous
savez vous qu'en 2025 vous serez 75 % de
la population active
et c'est pas à vous que je vais
apprendre à quel point votre vision de
l'entreprise vos attentes sont
différentes de celles de vos aînés
et oui vous cherchez des dirigeants qui
vous ressemble des dirigeants qui vous
comprennent des dirigeants qui partagent
vos valeurs
c'est vrai mais c'est pas vrai
c'est vrai c'est pas vrai
et oui ça me rappelle une anecdote avec
une chef de projet que je reçois pour un
poste en cdi le rêve est au bout d'une
heure elle me dit cette mission
m'intéresse énormément mais je ne veux
pas de cdi je veux un cdd parce que moi
dans un an je sais pas où je serai et je
n'ai pas du tout envie de m'engager
alors j'aurais pu arrêter tout de suite
l'entretien oui je cherche une cdi et en
fait j'ai été extrêmement touché par sa
sincérité j'ai été touché par le fait
qu'elle m'exprimais ses besoins de façon
tellement aligner de façon tellement
juste que j'ai ressenti le besoin et
l'on vit de travailler avec elle et ce
qui est fou c'est que l'année d'après
l'élu moi en me disant myriam j'aimerais
bien transformer ce cdd en cdi elle est
restée dix ans et on a une collaboration
extrêmement joyeuse ont mis le monde est
en mouvement pour que chacun joue sa
partition
le monde est en mouvement pour que
chacun puisse être aligné et puisse
jouer et vivre la magie d'être en lien
avec soi être en lien avec soin pour une
nouvelle gouvernance de notre vie de nos
choix de nos missions des organisations
et même du monde
le monde est en mouvement mais il est
important que chacun d'entre nous se met
en mouvement parce que ça dépend
essentiellement de nous de notre
capacité à nous mettre en mouvement pour
pouvoir vivre cette magie des troyens
avec soin
vous vous souvenez les trois clés
allez on y va
on écoute les signaux de notre corps
ensuite on entre ceux qui nous mettent
en joie pour comprendre ce qui nous
anime et troisièmement on fonce sur le
ring avec son sparring partner
et on dépose à son sparring partner ce
qui nous anime nos besoins ce dont on a
envie nos limites ce qu'on a envie de
faire de notre vie peut-être même ce
qu'on a envie d'apporter est ce qu'on a
envie de recevoir
et puis on fonce voir son dirigeant son
manager son actionnaire son futur boss
et on lui exprime tout cela on lui
exprime ce qu'on attend de lui ce qu'on
est prêt à lui donner et on lui demande
à lui à elle ses besoins et vous allez
voir comme tout s'enchaîne comme tout
s'éclaire
c'est absolument incroyable quand on
dépose de part et d'autre dans une
posture d'égal à égal
le monde a besoin de notre à nîmes en
individuel pour trouver son alignement
devenons les spécialistes de nous mêmes
et nous deviendrons les spécialistes de
tout le reste merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]